[Music]
nolan booth
the second most wanted art thief in the
world
special agent john hartley
fbi
hi guys
how'd you find me you stole william
strang's lady with the red hat from the
tape you can't hurt that was me
[Music]
i got that on etsy
i want you to help me catch the most
wanted art thief in the world
the bishop
hello boys it's so nice to finally meet
you in person
she set me up
frame me
a few clever keystrokes
bye-bye john hartley
she's gonna steal cleopatra's eggs
they're priceless we catch her together
i can clear my name and i'll help you
become the number one thief in the world
again lift with your neck even if i did
partner up with you
you still only have one brain
what's your plan son of a bit
see
easy peasy
you have to be the two dumbest man on
the planet you
look awful
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
how's it going with your partner in
crime
are you kidding me what this is
hard remember
there's my last name
[Music]
casting a thief can be dangerous
what
[Music]
[Music]
you